are you friends with Steven Spielberg I
went duck hunting with him once I guess
it was 95 because the Oscars were coming
up Steven called me up and goes hey
Quentin how would you like to go duck
hunting with me and Bob zemeckis and
John malias I'm like [ __ ] yeah I would
love to do that I mean I was this the
new kid in town and they were all really
impressed with with Pulp Fiction but one
of the things that Stephen wanted to do
is look you and Bob semccas are going to
be in competition the whole rest of this
year so before that competition starts
maybe it would be nice that we all go
off and do something together so we just
kind of keep in mind that you know we're
all artists and we're all friendly and
Spielberg said something that night and
he's like so here's what's going to
happen at the Oscars I don't think
you're going to win the Oscar I think
it's going to be Bob who's going to win
best picture and I think it's going to
be Bob who's going to win the best
director in fact I'm pretty sure of it
but I do think you will win best
original screenplay and then he stopped
and then turned around and looked at me
and goes second movie little gold man
not too bad I started walking